hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about
tech career and life so today again
we're going to talk about salary
negotiations
so i posted a video recently about
whether to negotiate your salary and so
today we're going gonna follow up and
talk about
how to exactly do that and this is from
my conversation that i had with sarah
who is the lead negotiator
at levels.fyi she was on muko's corner
in my show
about leading a life that feels more you
in both your life and tech career
sarah again just has like so much great
information from her time as a tech
recruiter
at amazon facebook and google to talk
about the do's and don'ts about how to
negotiate a salary so the topics covered
today will be like
how do you answer what are your salary
expectations and exactly what medium is
best for having these conversations
and before we get started i wanted to
say thank you to the sponsor of today's
video
skillshare as we're kind of in the mood
to like learn new skills like how to
negotiate your salary
skillshare is an incredible platform to
learn a lot of great things
it's an online learning community for
creative and curious people where
millions come together
to take the next step in their creative
journey skillshare is curated
specifically for learning meaning
there's no ads and they're always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused
and follow wherever your creativity
takes you and it's less than ten dollars
a month with an
annual premium subscription while we're
kind of on the topic of money i found a
really great course for how to build
good money habits
justin bridges who's a fashion
photographer and former finance pro
made this course modern money habits
five steps to build the life you want
the course includes gaining insight
about your current spending habits and
then also identifying small changes that
prevent debt
and then creating a realistic plan for
retirement and of course because i know
you all are tech people or curious about
tech they have tons of great classes
about coding as well
so check out skillshare and the first
1000 of my subscribers to click the link
in the description
will get a free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity
thanks again to skillshare and now let's
dive in okay
next i want to um talk more about like
how do you
actually negotiate specifically i have a
lot of questions about this but i guess
like
the first question that i had i think
this was one of the questions that i
really was
curious when we first started talking
was
when a recruiter asks you what are your
salary expectations
what's the best way like what's the
golden answer
uh the do's and don'ts of how to respond
to that question
don't give them that number don't give
them that range because
like i said the range is really large
you don't know where you land
in that compensation trend and so i
would recommend
push back on that recruiter and ask hey
i'm just really curious what is the
compensation
for this position and you don't have to
answer anything
either if you don't know the answer just
let them know hey i actually haven't put
much thought into this
this is a really important thing let me
just take some time to think about this
and can we revisit this later
and then you know usually recruiters are
pretty respectful of that
um another thing too is if you're in the
state of washington or california as the
candidate when you request for a
compensation ban
legally speaking they have to share the
minimum wage with you
and recently with denver 2 they pass a
law where credit where when they post
a job description they have to mention
like the minimum salary range
too so the recruiter can push for it the
recruiter can ask that is it anything in
place that you know tell them that they
can't ask
but ask the candidate to not obligate it
to you that's really good to know i
think in the past i recommended
to you all my viewers that you should
say i expect to be compensated
competitively
which is fine but i think instead of
flipping the question to them right
because
as soon as you put out a number out
there they you basically
might already be giving yourself away at
a discount uh which is great for the
company because then they're like wow we
get someone at this caliber for this
cheap great let's just like keep going
with their number when in fact you're
actually worth a lot more
exactly and it's just like you know once
you give a number the recruiter will
hold you to it
so you say 230k in total compensation
they will give you exactly that like
nothing more nothing less and let's say
you
start interviewing with another company
and they give you 300k
you can't come back and be like we're
just kidding like now i want 300k
you know now the recruiter can say wow
he came back
you know and tell me the other competing
offer which means that he really he or
she really wants this position
i'm not gonna move the needle and they
will eventually cave and it's about this
offer
you know if i'm really aggressive
recruiter don't do that
um and then another thing too when they
give you the range
don't say yes don't say no let's say you
flip it back on them and say hey i'm
just really curious what is the
compensation then for this position
and let's see the recruiter tell you all
right well the range is 100k
120k how does that sound to you do you
like this number
a voice saying yeah i know that sounds
great or
no that's really low keep things a
little bit more open-ended by saying
that's a really good start
so yeah have to work for yourself to
negotiate later
for sure yeah it's like you leave it as
lukewarm
as possible for as long as possible is
what i'm hearing
exactly what negotiation you want to be
you want to use really neutral like
verbage here you don't want to under
share but you don't want to over share
at the same time so then at what point
do you actually
like give a number or like who's the who
should be the first one to give
a number then i guess yeah so even at
the very end
when the recruiter you know share with
you the good news like
all right the team really loves you they
thought you do really well in abcd
see a lot of growth potential in you you
know we're ready to move on to the offer
stage
what are you looking for even at that
stage i still would recommend don't give
your number
uh sometime too you want to take this
call to really understand the
compensation philosophy
like they can't just be pushing for a
number when you don't tell you
when they don't tell you like what goes
into it right you can't make a decision
without being informed so push it back
on them and say
truthfully you know i've been really
busy prepping for the interview i
haven't put much thought into it
um if you don't mind just kind of going
over the compensation
structure with me first and then we can
go over perks and benefits
and then we'll take it from there and
you know once they go over everything
again
you can just push it back on them one
more time saying you know this is a
little bit newer for me and everyone has
different compensation structure
i know i'm not comparing apple to apple
if you don't mind just sharing the
numbers with me first it would be
super productive or effective or super
helpful for me
uh i would greatly appreciate it it's
almost like a game of poker i'm just
like
just waiting for them to fold just like
waiting and waiting and waiting waiting
and then having them be the first to
show their hand
exactly and like once the recruiter have
to explain everything for you they were
just like i might as well just share a
number now
right explain it later
right and like you mentioned at that
stage you've like already gone through
the entire interview process
you got a sense for the company culture
you got a sense of
what they're looking for in this role
you have their compensation
philosophy together you can piece all of
those together even
that when they give you a number you
have the data
and information to be able to
confidently say like
actually based on what i know and what
i've learned
i think i'm this much instead exactly
and you want to do a lot of the
asking good questions during that call
like asking about the bonus structure
how does that work
typically like when is the payout is it
once a year is it twice a year
is there any other bonuses on top of you
know what you guys
offer and things like that and for
companies that don't offer a bonus
that's the perfect window for you to use
that
as a leverage against them like hey
since you don't offer me any bonus what
i want to be mindful
of is inflation and you know living
costs that
just keep going up so essentially if i
don't take this into consideration now
the longer i stay with the company
essentially the less my take-home pay is
going to be
and i don't want to be in a position
where salary is a thing for me to
have to leave the company so i hope you
understand where i'm coming from
they can't say no to that you're going
to be the biggest [ __ ] if you say no
after that request right that's true
yeah use all of that knowledge you
learned in ap econ
to talk about inflation to talk about
money and use all of that to your
advantage
this whole conversation of this back and
forth between yourself and a recruiter
recruiter has a hiring manager and and
other folks behind them to um
make decisions about all of this but
what's the best format to be having this
conversation
yeah a good question so typically what i
would recommend do that
over via email you know after the
recruiter tells you we would love to
move forward
they go over the compensation structure
with you person benefit
let them know this is a lot of good
information let me just take some time
to process all of this and get back to
you later would that make sense for you
would that work for you
a as a recruiter for myself it's so much
easier
to you know kind of follow the thought
process because sometimes it's really
hard to like
maybe when i'm on the phone someone just
pinged me i got distracted maybe they
were asking me 140 but i misheard them
and i wrote down 104 for example
um so just to have everything on paper
is so much easier for the recruiter to
you know
not make any like mistake when it comes
to numbers there and let's say if i have
to
get an approval from their manager it's
so much easier for me to just kind of
forward that email
to the manager or the compensation team
so as a candidate you have so much more
control over your narrative
because you could be saying the perfect
thing but
communication goes both ways it's also
dependent on what the other side is
perceiving that message so if this
person
misunderstood what you were saying and
this person is relaying all this
information to the team
you don't know what ran what went wrong
in that process like things can go
sideways really fast
or maybe this recruiter just explained
something completely off
and the manager manager took it she
could take it the wrong way
and that kind of what could potentially
jeopardize your relationship with the
manager
it makes life so much easier on you to
do it over via email
because a lot of the time too i i would
see this happen with my friends where
they you know i'll prep them like ask
for this much and they were like yep
nope i got it and then we would rehearse
it and then when they're on the phone
they get so nervous that they start to
like discount themselves like
well i guess like i mean i kind of want
300k but like i would be
okay with 250 and i'm just like
oh no i'm just like oh what
the best analogy to think of this too is
when you send the recruiter an email
and then you have a call with them after
it's just the analogy of like
when you watch a movie and you read the
book before the movie is so much easier
to understand
right versus if you just watch the movie
and you've never seen
the i've never read the book before you
have no idea what's going on
in the movie so that's like kind of
taking the call without priming the
recruiter like what you're going to talk
about and you have to explain everything
live
they're just going to sit there and be
like okay like i guess
it makes sense but i'm not sure um so
email is the best way to go easier for
you to lay out your thought process
there
much easier for the recruiter to share
all that information with the team
you have so much more control over your
narrative thank you all so much for
watching the video i really hope you
liked it
make sure to check out the other video i
did about salary negotiations featuring
sarah
and if you'd like to just watch the
recording of the live stream i did on
mooco's corner
then you can become a member today by
clicking the join button down below
and get access to the full recording my
members help make muko's corner a
reality and also supports me in my
channel and allows me to do what i do
and if you haven't already the other way
you can support me is by clicking
subscribe
so take care and i'll see you in the
next video bye